s'ils gagnent et je suppose que tu est
parfaitement capable de me répéter
puisque nous sommes à l'aise madame vous
avez tous bien dire
tu peux donc vous dire qu'ils étaient
réversion de vuk épais pour me dire ça y
aura it à moi c'est unique
ce bond salut prochaine partant cinq
jours aujourd'hui l'arrivée au portugal
benoît xvi attente la vie des grès
malheureusement tu ne pourras pas nous
accompagner c'est quoi cette dette
serait de guasimal nous rejetons des
espoirs et non dans du vin délicat
des bus qui vont jusqu'au stade du
benfica
bon les gars corey laquelle un individu
pourrait être dangereux les autorités
comptent sur votre vigilance
tu nages dans le crotale tu dois prendre
de la hauteur
on fait quoi maintenant je m'en niveau
portugal en juin le feu de mes
entrailles brûlé poutres de ma raison
c'est carrément dimanche 6 à 10
pour répondre à ce groupe plutôt un bon
casse croûte de temps mais un coup
d'accord